zwei stück bin ich mache dann fangen
jetzt ganz normal machen warum das so
war die nicht vorher
ich hatte hier gesagt das tun aber das
merken lassen
der crafter dabei hallo und wir machen
beide uns jetzt eine curry
beziehungsweise ich mach's und luca
probiert leute ich bin voll dagegen dass
lena die ganze zeit so abwegig ist
ich meine das ja nicht so ernst so
andrea okay du hast mich ertappt
eigentlich hast du recht eigentlich ich
möchte immer nur nicht so sagen aber
eigentlich meine ich das genauso wie
sage so also ich mach mir eine quelle in
sachen im ziel mit aber ich einfach
nicht das mit was ich brauche immer weiß
wo sieht man seine portugal hat hatten
im inventar oder stoppen im winter hat
aber sonst wie ich demnächst mal kurz
ausland hätte mir sogar mehr erlaubt ist
der star war spannung also sonst muss
man immer so lang laufen wenn man eine
query aufstellt ist weit laufen weil man
weiß ja leider alter der so viele
schweine weil das total der ökonom total
der der tierschänder
unglaublich unglaublich hätte das muss
ein buch etwas machen das von
unterschiedlich die letzte vor du kannst
du da nicht welchen politikern habt dann
kann ich auf dem rückweg einfach direkt
nach hause zurück laufen sportportal
gehe also verkürzt die zeit ich zum
laufen benötigen die hälfte da stand in
faktor 05 um den faktor x wenig
verkürzen
egal wenigstens teilweise bekleidet ich
hab mich zum gold
also ich hab genau 16 das gut du bist so
ein clown und lebst ob ein baum 8 von
conny warum schreibst du so komische
sachen night live night live beste was
den lava gelandet so dann brauche ich
noch 28 kommissionen 8
wow
dass wir denen einfach alles
theatralisch das ist alter ich bin ich
bin mit der partei hoch runter gefallen
direkt in den quickborner raum
das war echt krass was eine theatralisch
ich wollte eigentlich nur seinen seinen
kisten raum halt finden ich hab ihn
gefunden
ich glaube ich war eben schon wo hat er
seine portable er seine elf diallo
hatten visiten apothekern aus die hatte
in seinem inventar homo
vielleicht hat er sie aber auch hier ich
glaube aber ich durch wahrscheinlich
hast du echt recht kleine ja ich glaub
dir mal
dann falsch alt nach hause hui
schattenparker von dem geld voll witzig
jeder meist halt ohne laufe ich halt so
wohin ceo alter gut ich muss die query
auch ich ständig rauf dann kommt den
stromversorgungen die wird über die
glasfaserkabel und ganz wichtig über die
vier solarpanels sich unten habe werden
die gespeist kloster wieder leistung man
da kann man nicht so technisch hand noch
billiger machen zu sagen was ich machen
so dass weder eingeplant also muss man
den stream machen alter möchte mal
wieder vorbeischauen auftritt punkte aus
lena und tv link in der beschreibung
und auch tv aber ich habe da mal dass
die gestreamt habe ich schon jahre her
ja ich da war ich da kann ich dir noch
gar nicht dabei hast du gesagt
den hat er ist ein cooler typ wirklich
gesagt ja ich konnte ich so was sagt man
ja eh wie auch voll gewundert wieso
wieso liegt er und so und da ja
ernsthaft aber noch nie zusammen
gesprochen hast du mit einem kumpel
zusammen gestreamt ja schon über ein
jahr her anderthalb jahre oder so
da war ich halt da irgendwie cd gespielt
nicht mehr auf dem spiel und wenn aus
dem könig der school bist du doch gar
nicht hier habe ich das gesagt wieso das
gesagt das weiß ich nicht
ja das war echt crazy sheep danach bin
ich schnell abgehakt peter fiedler
ich habe dich auch ganz normal gebucht
aber da waren wir schon mal geredet doch
sogar in dieser show geht er das war
genau das ist dann halt ein video
gemacht
die stars den macht coole videos schaut
mal vorbei und dann direkt danach was
ein livestream und ich kann sie dich
halt doch gar nicht und dann dachte okay
schaut mal rein spielt mal mit und dann
war heute im game cod war das halt und
so war schon im gang
und ja ich habe gesehen was die leistung
nach der kurs mal vorbei und danach soll
da gesagt hast halt meine haben dann in
game gesehen hast gesagt der ist sonys
korrekt ja kommen so der korrekte beuth
am see
ich weiß gar nicht wie viele abonnenten
da hat es aber ich glaube du hast also
56 7000 abonnenten auf jeden fall so
naja ich hab schon 1000 irgendwas aber
ich hätte auf jeden fall ab an einem tag
muss ich doch mal nach hessen dass der
steinbruch weil auf deutsch hast oder
was ja wie soll ich das auf dauer aber
das war das war dann halt das erste mal
dass irgendjemand größeres mich auf
gesehen hat irgendwie auf youtube und co
du bist
ich hätte diesen sprung nie geschafft ja
nie so gut war ist ein profi aber es
tragen aber ganz viele sei dies das
thema wie bist du so groß geworden
ja bestimmt auch oder wie bist du so
bekannt geworden und kannst du mich mal
pushen und so weiter sowas kommt der
andauern
und man kann sich einfach die social
bled statistiken angucken
bye bye bye dir bestimmt auch der
öffentlich von ihrem youtube-kanal oder
könnt ja genau gucken wie den koffer und
ich bei fast allen großen youtube
channels ist es so dass sie dann niemals
irgendwie so richtig krass gepusht
wurden nur deshalb großen zwischendurch
immer so klein erhöhen wenn man dann
irgendwie mit dem anderen aufgenommen
hat oder was aber das aber nie direkt
nie direkt am anfang so plus vier grad
plus 200 dann wieder niedrig weil alle
haben sich den anfang selbst erarbeitet
von uns zumindest und das ja machen die
meisten heute einfach nicht die machen
kein video schreiben unter videos
darunter jahren nervt mich mal im monat
mach mal dicker du wurdest doch bestimmt
auch günstiger mach mal etwas zurück als
nächste wurzel auch gepusht wie fühlst
du hoch gefolgt gibt doch zu ja gut ich
habe jetzt den steinbruch
ja das ist super damit hast du schon
ducati hat den test schon hinstellen
stromversorgung dran und er arbeitet
schon personen red engine ranmachen der
arbeitet
wenn ich dann in stromversorgungen daran
mache musste er eigene solarpanels von
stellen ja auch das jacket und
elektriker engines post auf jeden fall
eckel engines heißt ja die musste hier
bauen elektrische maschinen heißen ihren
vielleicht bei dir das weiß ich nicht
ich hab grad wieder auf deutsch gestellt
electricals engine nein ich bin im kreis
gelaufen
was machen die noch mal die die wandeln
halt in rom um von innerhalb von zb
solarpanels weil das ist ja andreas
trick kraft energie wandeln sie jungen
bildkraft energie die die quere benutzen
kann
ok direkt zu bauen es richtig
kompliziert das musst du dir nochmal im
singleplayer vorher ausprobieren weil
das wenig kompliziert vielleicht kannst
du die maschinen von sportics du hast
ein paar extra maschinen für kompliziert
ohne scheiß sagt er will ich's parkplatz
seine maschinen nutzen kann es habe ich
auch gemacht weil das musste extra
schienen bauen das sich nicht um das
echt doof und ich glaube da ich mir so
ein zettel gemacht meint agnes geschafft
und nachfolger das ist echt kompliziert
zu machen aber dann halt gerne terrex
hast kannst du es halt alles ziemlich
ehrlich machen deswegen ich würde es
immer empfehlen liegen um ein jet packs
ich mache hier meine quelle zwar von
einer stadt aber joel das heißt nach für
die landmark sehen nämlich eigentlich
noch machen
tacke wie komme ich jetzt am schnellsten
redstone ich brauche eure stone und und
und blu rays on state pisten
ich mache einfach den punkt hier das
eingangs freund waypoint dann okay und
ich glaube ich nochmals zurück und das
dürft ihr relativ schnell gehen
in diesem scheiss des punkt der mich an
schlechte zeiten in denen kinder
schichten könnte mir sowas passieren
genug stoff war meine schuhe keine
energie mehr weil die grand am series
wunsch und du kannst damit eigentlich
gar nicht sterben lassen lava button im
stück nicht mit zwei minuten lara bist
du stürzt nicht
aber sobald ein teil keine energie mehr
hart ist das nicht mehr so gut wie ein
diamant rüstung wenn man wenn man was
nicht mehr hat denn wenn ein teil keine
energiemärkte nachrüstung nicht gut
nein das war sehr doof das macht keinen
spaß dass ich leider gar nicht schön 19
electricals engine die für häufig davon
zwei stück will ich mach doch dann
fangen jetzt erst als normal machen
warum das so war die nicht vorher
ich hatte hier gesagt hast du aber das
müssen wir merken
ich habe dich zu sehen da kommt der iron
oder aus da kommt dass daraus dann kommt
er das 3
ich möchte mich eigentlich noch indirekt
machen das ding ist nur dass es so
kompliziert ist deswegen ich doch gesagt
lass erstmal weil ich selbst ich mache
mir gerade noch ein direkt ich würde mir
noch ein machen für energie weil dann
musste die energieversorgung kannst du
zu hause haben und die kann ich geklaut
werden
mal so wie du es jetzt machst muss die
energieversorgung zu hause sein und die
stumpf und die items das sind auch die
karies die stromversorgung muss direkt
an der krems an
du hast gesagt die stromversorgungs
pause sein duomo ich meine es andersrum
aber halt wenn du mit projektarbeit ist
kannst du die stromversorgung auch zu
hause machen ist nur direkter wenn du
dir auf privat stellt kann er glaube ich
nicht mehr abgebaut werden das das
einzige was geklaut werden kann die
credit selbst und diese extrem aufwendig
oder ist das für dich aufwendig gewesen
ja ich weiß nicht wie weit die weg bauen
soll was für die was für euch weiter
heisst ob man truck der entfernung
machen sie's ja mit der minimap 1006
entweder ja also ich mach doch mal 1000
das risiko ist dass geklaut wird aber
ich hab kein bock weiter weg zu laufen
1000 dann unter der erde oder wie ich
mach's über der trends unter wäre macht
es dir wahrscheinlichkeit sehr gering
dass jemand findet findet wenn er sich
nicht bald die koordinaten auf schreibt
man kann sich auf jeden fall weiter
abbauen bevor die folge online geht
aber ich glaube keiner von uns aufnehmen
kann die leute zuschauerplätzen wir
gerne ja eben wendel wenden wenn sie
dann schreibt es vorbei an den kommentar
klar dass und das dass es darunter suche
vorinstalliert wird was ihr schreiben
könnt wenn über den etwas müsste dann
hallo ich herzlich so viel geschenkt dem
journalisten und vips denen macht jedoch
nicht in baku wieder okay bin ich halt
ein sparkurs mit mir leid ich mache mir
da noch sein electric so jetzt habe ich
aber auch nicht alles lernt man schon an
die kiste ich muss hier alles irgendwann
mal sicher brauche aber ein ich habe ich
alles
dann mache ich das jetzt wollen wir
schlafen nicht ja oder nein nein
na gut dann nicht weit weg teilnehmer
schlafen nicht
ok bitte doch schlafen warum hier angst
im dunkeln
du stehst auf dem bett oder nicht ja
okay ich bin bett kommen wollte sind
nicht klar bin auch im batman schlug
also ein geregelter schlaf ist das a und
o was machst du gerade ist voll
komplizierter ist voll mäßig da
verstrickt um irgendwas ganz simples
zugreifen
immer wenn ich jetzt was richtig
kompliziert ist mache dann rede ich
einfach nicht richtig viel
ja ich mache jetzt jeder das macht er
richtig unglaublich viel spaß und
blablabla excel dienstes fertig so gehe
ich habe zwei elektriker engine und in
der prärie wundervoll und wie mache ich
das jetzt machen auch noch im bau da
brauchst du brauchst ganz viele kisten
adios anstellen welche gewürze mir
empfehlen goldpreis wenn nun endlich
gold hast wenn du hast du viel gold du
brauchst dafür kaum gold für acht boxer
zwei gold habe kein gold
du hast aber dann macht ihr gold mit
schau ma yue yue meter wie du damit gold
master an hast du richtig viel kohle
wenige meter
das lohnt schon weiß einfach schneller
als geht kleine brauchte sich macht mit
carlson aber ist total juli
und ansonsten braucht gar nicht gar
nichts du brauchst noch besser sortiert
machen
du kannst pipes maniche wird vor allem
was machen die massen mit tintenfisch
und irgendwas anderem müssen mal gucken
dann die teleportiert items du nicht
brauchst direkt ins ins nichts
wer redet da werde ich etwas nach
koketterie etwas wide webs idee was mit
denen du musst du machen dann kannst du
zum beispiel der cup ist dann außerdem
bei sonst hast du 300 kisten mit kristin
fall also die müssen sofort aus wenn das
hatte ich auch bei mir daher ist also
carlsson und er hat und sein außerdem
hatte sonst hat das zu viel zu vielen
das brauchst du gar nicht deshalb die
idee ich weiß nicht wie es auf deutscher
ist ich habs jetzt auch auf englisch
so beugt transport brauchst du einfach
nur die er braucht ein redstone allein
klingt und ein glas und möglichst acht
stück brauchst nur ein oder zwei je
nachdem wie viele teams herausfiltern
willst das ist dann alles okay okay
und dann braucht halt kabels und wenn du
willst deine maps damit kannst du halt
sagen was in welche kiste soll aber dann
brauchst keinen ja und was was willst du
mir jetzt genau empfehlen
genau um die credit transfer an equally
dran zu machen
du meinst was direkt an zu machen wie
was denkt ans web direkt an die curry
gold oder eine kappe und eine schnelle
aber schnelligkeit der eigentlich egal
ich kann schon wichtig wie beim fußball